I signed up to Breck's and I got three
or four hundred some hundreds of
thousands of dollars in like 12 hours
yeah right ramp uh let's ramp something
hey it's bass out in ears Breck's but
from New York yeah I'm into it it
launched today ok so I went my company
we do let's say mmm eight figures a year
in revenue we have not seven figures in
cash well I have been using one big bank
for a long time and to get us to raise
our credit-card limit from 30,000 to
80,000 was a nightmare oh my god a
nightmare
yeah I had to go meet them in person two
or three times I had a show that my
personal Sam Parrs
tax returns it was stupid I signed up to
Breck's and I got three or four hundred
some hundreds of thousands of dollars in
like 12 hours yeah awesome and I told
these guys in like yeah we can't compete
with that
oh okay all right this conversation is
over thank you so I really like this new
business credit card space and I explain
how I think they're making money but
ramp just launched and what they're
gonna do what they said they're gonna do
is they're gonna analyze all your credit
card spending and they'll tell you where
repetitive purchases are coming through
and I actually mentioned this on the
podcast three months ago I was like I'm
telling you that businesses are wasting
so much money by buying multiple
subscriptions of things and I think
something amazing can be built by
helping you save a little bit of money
right that's what this is that's like a
side feature they have that's not like
the main feature is the same like bricks
right like it's like here's a business
credit card well that's how they're
differentiating Breck's is advertising
says we will get you better rewards
right and this is will save your money
yeah and I think it's cool and I'm
really bullish on those things and I
think the way they work is whenever a
whenever a customer when I have my
credit card and I go and buy something
the merchant pays a 4% fee and what
Breck's does is they go to master car
and they go hey you guys are getting a
four percent fee for all this stuff
give us a cut of that and we'll create
more credit card users right and I think
that's how they're making money I'd
imagine
I think so I don't know I don't know for
certain but
[Music]